Hey guys, this is Jay from Boston.
大家好，我是来自波士顿的杰伊。
In 2008, I moved to Boston for my first job out of college, and I was so excited to be in a bigger city and be with my friends and make new ones and go on adventures and be single.
2008年，我搬到了波士顿，开始了大学毕业后的第一份工作，我很高兴能来到一个更大的城市，和我的朋友在一起，结交新朋友，继续冒险，保持单身。
And then I had my Ted and Robin meet cute moment of sorts.
然后我让泰德和罗宾遇到了某种可爱的时刻。
I wasn't in a bar.
我当时不在酒吧。
I was in my office, but across the office, even though I swore I was going to be single for a while, I locked eyes with the woman who is now my wife.
我在办公室里，但在办公室的另一边，尽管我发誓要单身一段时间，但我的目光却与现在是我妻子的女人对视了。
wife.
妻子。
I was already a huge himmium fan and always identified with Ted, somebody who felt deeply and got hurt badly and fell in love fast and wanted to skip the dating stuff to be good at the relationship stuff but maybe didn't want to admit that to myself at the time.
我已经是他的超级粉丝了，总是认同泰德，一个感情深厚、受过重伤、很快坠入爱河的人，想跳过约会的事情，擅长处理人际关系，但当时可能不想向自己承认这一点。
And so my wife and I spent several years after that moment with this really tight knit group having our adventures around the city being young being in our 20s and then we had our first child in 2018 and our second a few years later and this brings me to this underexplored way we watch the show.
因此，在那之后的几年里，我和我的妻子与这个非常紧密的团队一起度过了几年，我们在 20 多岁的时候在城市里冒险，然后我们在 2018 年生下了我们的第一个孩子，几年后我们有了第二个孩子，这让我想到了我们观看这部剧的这种未经探索的方式。
There's a phrase you you hear about when you become a new parent, the phrase is loss of identity.
当你成为新父母时，你会听到一个短语，这个短语就是“身份的丧失”。
As a parent, you experience a loss of identity.
作为父母，您会经历身份的丧失。
And for all the happiness you feel, all the love and fulfillment you receive, you also mourn pieces of yourself that you don't have time or energy to access or that you have to leave behind.
尽管你感受到了所有的幸福，你收到了所有的爱和满足，但你也会哀悼自己那些你没有时间或精力去获取或你必须抛弃的部分。
You feel a loss of identity.
你感到失去了身份。
And I often think about my days roaming the city with all my friends, daydreaming about the future or just the infinite hours we had at our disposal after brunch on a Saturday.
我经常想起我和所有朋友在城市里漫游的日子，幻想着未来，或者只是周六早午餐后我们可以随意支配的无限时间。
And watching himium today hits different for me because it gives me access to a version of myself, to a major source of my identity, which honestly has been lost as I grew older and became a parent.
今天观看《himium》对我来说有不同的感受，因为它让我接触到自己的一个版本，接触到我身份的主要来源，老实说，随着我年龄的增长和成为父母，这种来源已经消失了。
And I don't want that version back.
我不想要那个版本。
Nothing is better in my life than being a dad to my two wonderful kids.
在我的生活中，没有什么比成为我两个可爱孩子的父亲更好的了。
But it helps me feel whole when I watch the show if I have moments of feeling flattened.
但当我观看节目时，如果我有感到沮丧的时刻，它会让我感觉完整。
It helps me laugh at what we used to be and to see it fondly, not sadly.
它帮助我嘲笑我们曾经的样子，并深情地看待它，而不是悲伤。
Those days and how I met your mother are part of my identity.
那些日子以及我如何认识你母亲是我身份的一部分。
So thank you for making this show.
所以谢谢你制作这个节目。
Thank you for this wonderful re-watch and all the philosophy that comes out in these episodes.
感谢您的精彩重看以及这些剧集中所体现的所有哲学。
Oh, and if you're wondering, just like Ted, my kids are an older girl and a younger boy.
哦，如果你想知道，就像特德一样，我的孩子是一个年龄较大的女孩和一个年龄较小的男孩。
And yeah, they're already used to getting cornered on the couch as I make them hear the story over and over again of how I met their mother.
是的，当我让他们一遍又一遍地听我如何遇见他们母亲的故事时，他们已经习惯了被困在沙发上。
I'm alone, but we soon, in New York City, when I see you, please permit me to tell you everything, York City.
我独自一人，但我们很快就会在纽约市，当我见到你时，请允许我告诉你一切，纽约市。
Wow.
哇。
That's a great message.
这是一个很棒的信息。
Yeah.
是的。
That was fantastic.
那太棒了。
Thank you for that.
谢谢你。
I wish you could have seen me and Craig and our Secret Extra Special Secret guest.
我希望你能看到我和克雷格以及我们的 Secret Extra Special Secret 嘉宾。
We were just delighted listening to that.
我们很高兴听到这个。
And it's so funny.
这太有趣了。
I was telling Craig, I just got back from LA.
我告诉克雷格，我刚从洛杉矶回来。
I went there last week for a little work.
我上周去那里做一些小工作。
And I really was hit with this wave of nostalgia the before times, the life that was kind of that I was forging in L.A.
我真的被这股怀旧浪潮所击中，那是我在洛杉矶打造的生活。
there.
那里。
I worked with Craig for so long and it's not that I want that life back.
我和克雷格一起工作了这么久，我并不是想回到那种生活。
It's just there's sometimes like sadness that it's all over because I'm a nostalgic person.
只是有时会感到悲伤，一切都结束了，因为我是一个怀旧的人。
If you ever saw my movie liberal arts, I get sad when things end.
如果你看过我的电影文科，当事情结束时我会感到难过。
But also even if when the present is wonderful, which it is right now.
但即使现在是美好的，就在现在。
So I'm just so delighted that that's another in road into how I met.
所以我很高兴这是我认识的另一条道路。
We could actually do an entire episode on just that.
我们实际上可以为此制作一整集。
I feel like you wrote everything that he just said.
我感觉他刚才说的一切都是你写的。
Like that was your like that is so what you're talking about right now.
就像那是你的样子，这就是你现在所说的。
That's Rhett and Noreen.
那是瑞德和诺琳。
It was Rhett and Noreen.
是瑞德和诺琳。
It was Class Crenor and also you can't convince me that it wasn't Ezra Klein.
那是克雷诺班，但你也无法让我相信那不是埃兹拉·克莱因。
That sounded so much like Ezra Klein.
这听起来很像埃兹拉·克莱因。
And I mean it as a compliment to both Ezra and Jay.
我的意思是这是对以斯拉和杰伊的赞美。
Very intelligent, very elegant.
非常聪明，非常优雅。
Yeah, Jay, thank you for that.
是的，杰伊，谢谢你。
Jay, great message.
杰伊，很棒的消息。
We should probably introduce ourselves.
我们或许应该自我介绍一下。
We just started, we just kind of launched in.
我们才刚刚开始，我们才刚刚开始。
My name is Josh Radner.
我叫乔什·拉德纳。
I started on a TV show called How I Met Your Mother from 2005 to 2014.
2005 年至 2014 年，我开始出演一部名为《老爸老妈浪漫史》的电视节目。
I played a character named Ted Mosby.
我扮演了一个名叫特德·莫斯比的角色。
Craig Thomas, who's with me tonight as he is with all these episodes.
克雷格·托马斯，今晚他和我在一起，就像他和所有这些剧集一样。
He co-created this show with Carter Bayes.
他与卡特·贝叶斯共同创作了这个节目。
Hi, Craig.
嗨，克雷格。
Hey there, I forgot the part we're introducing our cell phone.
嘿，我忘了我们介绍手机的部分了。
We'll send him out to our guest that was jumping in to our guest.
我们将把他派给跳进我们客人身边的客人。
We're getting into, we're now on the third episode of the third season.
我们正在进入第三季的第三集。
We're having a great time.
我们玩得很开心。
We're enjoying it so much.
我们非常享受它。
My wife, Jordana, has never seen the show.
我的妻子乔丹娜从未看过这个节目。
She's really enjoying it.
她真的很享受。
So, Craig, we, T.S.
所以，克雷格，我们，T.S.
up here, we have an extra special, exciting guest here with us tonight.
今晚，我们这里有一位特别、令人兴奋的客人。
We sure do.
我们当然会。
Who do we have with us?
谁和我们在一起？
So we have a amazing writer with us who was sadly only only on season three with us, but season three, a super pivotal make or break turning point season for the show.
因此，我们有一位出色的编剧，遗憾的是，他只和我们一起完成了第三季，但第三季是该剧的一个超级关键的成败转折点。
This gentleman was a total all star and helped.
这位绅士是一位全明星，并且提供了帮助。
I think that was the crucial pivot point to when the show really became a thing.
我认为这是该剧真正成为主流的关键点。
And you were you were there, my friend, the great writer of TV, of film.
我的朋友，伟大的电视、电影作家，你也在场。
He's a lawyer, He's a billion things.
他是一名律师，他有十亿个身份。
He's an Oscar nominee.
他是奥斯卡提名者。
He's a writer's guild award winner, writer of the movie, The Holdovers, which we are all super fans of this year.
他是作家协会奖得主，也是电影《The Holdovers》的编剧，我们今年都是这部电影的超级粉丝。
Fantastic.
极好的。
And this podcast, the great Dave Hemmingson.
还有这个播客，伟大的戴夫·海明森。
Well, Dave Hemmingson.
好吧，戴夫·海明森。
You guys are so kind.
你们真是太善良了。
You're so kind.
你真善良。
I'm thrilled to be here.
我很高兴来到这里。
Now, remember so fondly.
现在回想起来，是那么的深情。
I will tell this story real quick, Craig, I don't know if you remember.
我会很快地讲这个故事，克雷格，我不知道你是否还记得。
So Craig and Carter and I were on a show called American Dad.
所以克雷格、卡特和我参加了一个名为《美国爸爸》的节目。
That's how we met.
我们就是这样认识的。
Still on the air.
仍在播出。
20 years later.
20年后。
That's still fucking on the air.
这他妈的还在播出。
We're on season one together, and Carter and Craig had a Fox pilot in a CBS pilot that year.
我们一起出演第一季，卡特和克雷格那一年在哥伦比亚广播公司的试播节目中观看了福克斯的试播节目。
And that's 2004.
那是2004年。
2004, yeah.
2004年，是的。
2004, I had a Fox pilot and a CBS pilot.
2004 年，我有一名福克斯飞行员和一名哥伦比亚广播公司飞行员。
We both had Fox and CBS pilots.
我们都有福克斯和哥伦比亚广播公司的飞行员。
Yeah.
是的。
I ended up creating a show called Kitchen Confidential.
我最终制作了一个名为《厨房机密》的节目。
My CBS pilot didn't go, thank you.
我的哥伦比亚广播公司飞行员没有去，谢谢。
My Fox pilot went, starring Bradley Cooper.
我的福克斯试播集去了，由布莱德利·库珀主演。
We got nominated for the Irish Guild Award for that show, but four episodes and out, right?
我们因该剧获得爱尔兰行会奖提名，但已经播出四集了，对吧？
Four episodes and out.
四集就完结了。
Was it only four?
只有四个吗？
Yeah, we did.
是的，我们做到了。
Damn it.
该死的。
We aired four and out.
我们播出了四集就结束了。
These guys go nine years.
这些家伙已经九年了。
I was ecstatic for them and I was thrilled to join in season three because I was like, you guys got, you had the magic, the special sauce and the genius to create this incredible show, which I think is remarkable in so many material ways.
我为他们感到欣喜若狂，我很高兴能加入第三季，因为我想，你们有魔法、有特殊的酱汁和天才来创造这个令人难以置信的节目，我认为这在很多物质方面都是非凡的。
I mean, I talked to so many people who love himium, but also just that the way you play with time and space and perspective and kind of almost a Rashomon thing that you guys were doing.
我的意思是，我和很多热爱“himium”的人交谈过，但也正是你们玩弄时间、空间和视角的方式，以及你们所做的几乎是罗生门的事情。
I remember reading that pilot and being not as much jealous, but happy and like, God damn it, I wish I'd come up with that idea because I always thought it was a genius idea.
我记得读过那个试播集后，我并没有那么嫉妒，而是很高兴，天哪，我希望我能想出这个主意，因为我一直认为这是一个天才的主意。
So for me to be invited to join you guys in season three was huge for me and I mean so much happened that season between the to sell us this more arc, and what else?
所以对我来说，被邀请加入第三季对我来说意义重大，我的意思是那个赛季发生了很多事情，为了向我们推销更多的弧线，还有什么？
We had Britney Spears, we had Britney Spears, we had a writer's guilt strike, we had like my son being born, and that was like life altering for me.
我们有布兰妮·斯皮尔斯，我们有布兰妮·斯皮尔斯，我们有作家的内疚罢工，我们有我儿子的出生，这就像改变我的生活。
Like there was a trillion things going on.
就像有上万亿的事情正在发生。
And Dave, it was a real All-Star at the same studio.
戴夫（Dave）是同一工作室的真正全明星。
You're under a deal at the same studio as us.
你和我们在同一个工作室签订了协议。
That's where we're on all these same shows and pitching, you know, at same times and things.
这就是我们在相同的时间和地点参加所有这些相同的节目和宣传的地方。
We were on a deal, and we were very lucky.
我们达成了协议，我们非常幸运。
You got off of American Dad to go do kitchen confidential, and that's why you were even free, because American dad would probably never have let you go.
你离开美国爸爸去厨房保密，这就是为什么你甚至是自由的，因为美国爸爸可能永远不会让你走。
Dave was like the funniest guy in the American dad room.
戴夫就像美国爸爸房间里最有趣的人。
You have a true like hilarity in a writer's room.
在作家的房间里，你会感受到真正的欢闹。
Like you're a Robin Williams-esque like no, like go, go, go, like machine gun energy.
就像你是罗宾·威廉姆斯式的，不，就像走，走，走，就像机关枪的能量。
And you were so fucking funny in that American dad room that we were like, we gotta get Dave if we can get him.
你在那个美国爸爸的房间里真是太有趣了，我们就像，如果我们能得到戴夫，我们就得到他。
Dave, were you only contracted for one year on how I met your mother?
戴夫，你只与我和你母亲的认识签订了一年的合同吗？
Was that what they did?
他们就是这么做的吗？
I was.
我是。
It was an overall deal.
这是一项整体交易。
So I could kind of rotate, you know, these overall deals were also called show overalls at the time.
所以我可以轮换，你知道，这些整体交易当时也被称为表演工作服。
So unless you sort of were developing and had your own pilot, you would rotate amongst very shows.
因此，除非您正在开发并拥有自己的飞行员，否则您将在各个节目之间轮换。
And so I got off American Dad to do kitchen.
于是我就离开美国爸爸去做厨房了。
Kitchen was a year.
厨房用了一年。
It went down after 13 episodes and my heart was lacerated and destroyed.
13集之后就停播了，我的心被撕裂和摧毁了。
I was like, oh my God, how could this go away?
我当时想，天啊，这怎么可能消失呢？
It was really brutal.
真的很残酷。
But I had the great good fortune of having met and having fallen in love with Carter and Craig and they were so gracious to invite me on to him even in season three.
但我很幸运能够认识并爱上卡特和克雷格，即使在第三季，他们也非常慷慨地邀请我加入他。
And so I was just thrilled to be there.
所以我很高兴能在那里。
And I think subsequent to, I went off and did another pilot, so I left him in.
我想之后，我又去做了另一次试播，所以我把他留了下来。
So when you were these overalls back in the day, and I arrived back in the Fox lot, I've been here for 12 years at the time.
所以，当你穿上这些工作服时，我又回到了福克斯球场，当时我已经在这里呆了 12 年了。
I was on the Fox lot from 2005 to 2015, I want to say.
我想说，从 2005 年到 2015 年，我一直在福克斯工作。
So.
所以。
That's so funny.
太有趣了。
You're there right now.
你现在就在那里。
You're talking to us from there.
你正在那里和我们说话。
I was like right, like my old offices, like right down the way there.
我的感觉是对的，就像我以前的办公室一样，就在那边。
But I was really blessed and really lucky to be invited on because that was the most, the most, first of all, the cast was genius, is genius.
但我真的很幸运，很幸运能被邀请，因为那是最，最，首先，演员阵容是天才，是天才。
Doug Ryder's room was extraordinary.
道格·莱德的房间非同寻常。
If you think about the people there, they were in the net room, you know?
如果你想想那里的人，他们就在网房里，你知道吗？
And I was just honored to be a part of it, honored to be a part of it.
我很荣幸成为其中的一部分，很荣幸成为其中的一部分。
Yeah, it was a magic season.
是的，那是一个神奇的赛季。
That was the turning point season for me for the show.
那是我这部剧的转折点。
I just think that was where it really could have gone one way or the other kind of, and it went the good way.
我只是认为这确实可以以某种方式或另一种方式发展，而且进展顺利。
When we watched the first season, I was like, oh my God, we really came out of the gate strong.
当我们观看第一季时，我想，天哪，我们真的很强大。
Like the first five or six episodes of this show itself are really incredible.
就像这个节目本身的前五六集一样，真的令人难以置信。
And I'm now, I've seen four of the episodes of season three, and I'm like, all incredible.
现在，我已经看过第三季的四集，我觉得一切都令人难以置信。
Like the beginning to this season, I think is just all guns firing, you know?
就像本赛季开始时一样，我认为一切都是枪声，你知道吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
Agree.
同意。
In watching this episode, so Dave Hemmingson wrote the episode third wheel.
在观看这一集时，戴夫·海明森 (Dave Hemmingson) 写了第三轮这一集。
I think we just called it third wheel.
我想我们只是称之为第三轮。
I'm not sure there's a lot.
我不确定有很多。
It's kind of like a Facebook thing.
这有点像 Facebook 的事情。
Yeah, third wheel.
是的，第三轮。
Yeah, I tell third wheel.
是的，我告诉第三轮。
And I coined that phrase and had the idea for sort of what this episode is gonna be.
我创造了这个短语，并对这一集的内容有了想法。
And which I, this very real time, like high stakes, takes place all in one night, like shot out of a cannon, like a lot of things that are great about Great Hemium.
而我，这个非常真实的时间，就像高风险一样，在一夜之间发生，就像从大炮中射出，就像伟大的赫米姆的很多伟大的事情一样。
It's a certain kind of Great Hemium episode that I think you came in and you just had that brain.
这是某种伟大的 Hemium 情节，我认为你进来了并且你就是有那个大脑。
Dave is a brilliant guy.
戴夫是一个才华横溢的人。
If I'm remembering correctly, you went to Yale, you went to Columbia, you were a lawyer, you like all these things before you were ever a TV writer.
如果我没记错的话，你去了耶鲁大学，你去了哥伦比亚大学，你是一名律师，在你成为电视作家之前你喜欢所有这些事情。
So you came in and you kind of cracked the code, you're like one night, real time, boom, keep this thing urgent and suspenseful.
所以你进来了，你破解了密码，你就像一个晚上，实时，繁荣，让这件事保持紧急和悬念。
And so it's you came in and we're just great with this episode.
所以你进来了，我们对这一集感到非常满意。
And I really loved it.
我真的很喜欢它。
I loved how it had a sense of urgency.
我喜欢它的紧迫感。
I hadn't rewatched it in a long, long time until last night.
直到昨晚，我已经很久很久没有重看了一遍。
And I thought it was great to rewatch.
我觉得重看真是太好了。
You know, Craig, it's just occurring to me that the energy of Lily, Marshall, and Barney in Ranjit's cab or in Ranjit's car in the pilot is mirrored in this episode.
你知道，克雷格，我刚刚想到，在试播集中，莉莉、马歇尔和巴尼在兰吉特的出租车或兰吉特汽车里的能量在这一集中得到了反映。
It's in this.
就在这里面。
It is.
这是。
They're his Indy 500 pit crew.
他们是他的印地 500 维修站工作人员。
They're there in real time.
他们是实时存在的。
keep him on the race, you know what I mean?
让他继续比赛，你明白我的意思吗？
And that's, this episode of, yeah, I love the shifting agendas the way that Barney sort of like kicks into a certain girdle late in the episode.
这就是这一集，是的，我喜欢不断变化的议程，就像巴尼在这一集后期踢到某个腰带的方式一样。
How would he say like, I'll have Marshall's sort of resistance to the idea that he couldn't have pulled it off.
他会怎么说，我会像马歇尔一样抵制他不可能成功的想法。
Like, I love how in backing Ted, there's, their respective agenda is kind of like percolate to the surface.
就像，我喜欢支持特德，他们各自的议程有点像渗透到表面。
And there's this sort of like circular firing squad in the bedroom.
卧室里有一个类似圆形的行刑队。
Like there's so much I love about that, you know, episode.
就像我非常喜欢那一集一样。
Yeah.
是的。
So, just to, just to ground our viewers like, uh, so this episode, Third Wheel, written by Dave Hemingson, it's the third episode of the third season.
所以，只是为了让我们的观众接地气，呃，所以这一集《第三轮》，由戴夫·海明森编写，是第三季的第三集。
Alec, what is the air date of this episode?
亚历克，这一集的播出日期是哪天？
This aired on October 8th, 2007.
该节目于2007年10月8日播出。
Right after it was with Brady Bunch was our lead in and then it went into a little house.
就在与布雷迪·邦奇 (Brady Bunch) 比赛之后，我们就领先了，然后比赛就进入了一座小房子。
So I'm always curious of the DNA.
所以我一直对DNA很好奇。
We get the scripts a couple days before the table read, but you guys have been living with this stuff for a while.
我们在比赛前几天拿到了剧本，但你们已经和这些东西相处了一段时间了。
that the long tail is long for you guys.
长尾巴对你们来说很长。
So do you remember, was this your pitch, Dave?
那么你还记得，这是你的推销吗，戴夫？
And just also maybe Dave can even say, like just summarize this episode, like what happens in this episode?
也许戴夫甚至可以说，就像总结这一集，就像这一集中发生了什么？
Well, this actually is a callback to season one because the pineapple girl appears in this one.
嗯，这实际上是第一季的回调，因为菠萝女孩出现在这一季中。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
But the basic line, the basic, the bottom line in this one, the log line would be Ted is afforded an opportunity that is not normally afforded to many men.
但基本的、基本的、底线的这一点，日志线将是特德被提供了一个通常不会为许多人提供的机会。
And then two girls sort of are both interested in at the same time and not opposed to sort of kind of engaging with forces, United Forces, kind of a super friends way, kind of a sexual super friends.
然后，两个女孩同时对某种与力量、联合力量、某种超级朋友方式、某种性超级朋友的接触感兴趣，而不是反对。
By the way, there's your show.
顺便说一下，还有你的表演。
Whatever you're like, now I'm putting this on right now, I'm sure this.
不管你是什么样的人，现在我就戴上它，我确信这一点。
I could do that on only fans, but no, the long and shortness of like, he has afforded this thing that is sort of mythic amongst the dude sometimes and he's sort of trying to figure out, he's confronted with excitement, doubt, anxiety, uncertainty.
我只能在粉丝身上做到这一点，但不，长短之类的，他提供了这种有时在这家伙中有点神秘的东西，他有点试图弄清楚，他面临着兴奋、怀疑、焦虑和不确定性。
Can he measure up?
他能达到标准吗？
He's got an Obi-Wan in the persona of Neil and at the same time a competitor and And there's jealousy and regret and all kind of marriage.
他扮演着尼尔的欧比旺角色，同时也是一个竞争对手，还有嫉妒、遗憾和各种各样的婚姻。
There's so much happening.
发生了很多事情。
There's so many emotions.
有这么多的情感。
Yeah, because it's sort of like this sort of, you know, and I love Lily's attitude toward the whole thing.
是的，因为这有点像这样，你知道，我喜欢莉莉对整件事的态度。
Like the whole thing is just great.
好像整件事都很棒。
So anyway, he's afforded this opportunity with these two girls.
所以无论如何，他给了这两个女孩这个机会。
They're both interested in him and not not opposed to sort of making it as the friend say, I'm an agitoua.
他们都对他感兴趣，并且并不反对像朋友所说的那样，我是一个阿吉图阿。
And he is just sort of excited, overwhelmed.
他只是有点兴奋，不知所措。
I don't know, Josh, when you read it, what were you thinking?
我不知道，乔什，当你读到它时，你在想什么？
I was wondering about it too, Josh.
我也想知道这个问题，乔什。
What do you think?
你怎么认为？
When you read it?
你什么时候读的？
What are you doing?
你在干什么？
Well, first of all, I want to say in the watching of it, I think you could not write, and I don't mean this as a ding against the episode.
好吧，首先，我想说的是，在观看它的过程中，我认为你不能写，我并不是说这是对这一集的批评。
It's the most wholesome episode about a threesome that you could ever write, you know what I mean?
这是你能写过的关于三人行的最健康的一集，你知道我的意思吗？
It's got like a very sweet spirit.
它就像一种非常甜蜜的精神。
There's nothing like kind of feel like it's like everyone, including the audience, you're like, get the belt, like we want to get the rooting for Ted, the rooting for Ted is the rooting for him.
没有什么比这感觉就像每个人，包括观众，你都想，获得腰带，就像我们想要为泰德加油一样，对泰德的支持就是对他的支持。
I think that I remember really liking the energy of Ted at the beginning of the season and maybe you'll remember this.
我想我记得我真的很喜欢特德在赛季开始时的活力，也许你会记得这一点。
I don't know if you were involved in some of these network meetings, but Carter and Craig told me that they wanted to explore what it's like if Ted and Barney were really out on the town together.
我不知道你是否参加过其中一些网络会议，但卡特和克雷格告诉我，他们想探索一下如果特德和巴尼真的一起出城会是什么样子。
Ted is single, he's had his heart broken, he really gave it a go with Robin.
泰德是单身，他的心都碎了，他真的尝试过和罗宾在一起。
What would this be like?
这会是什么样子？
And I think we were, this was still pre Craig where they kind of pulled Ted back.
我想我们还是在克雷格之前，他们把特德拉了回来。
Yes.
是的。
You know, where they, yeah.
你知道，他们在哪里，是的。
They wanted him to retain his kind of DNA of the pilot, you know, that he was this guy who was really interested more in relationships than in casual hookups, but I feel like there was something about this episode that just allowed, I really liked the way that he was, he was pretty loose with these women.
他们希望他保留飞行员的DNA，你知道，他是一个对人际关系比对随意的勾搭更感兴趣的人，但我觉得这一集有一些东西让我真的很喜欢他的方式，他对这些女人非常放松。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Like, he was charming.
就像，他很有魅力。
He was, he had like an ease about- Very charming.
他，他有一种轻松的感觉——非常迷人。
It was not gross.
这并不恶心。
It was not like lecherous.
这不像是好色的。
It was like very, He's like a little kid.
就像非常，他就像一个小孩子。
He's just like this little like, it's Christmas morning.
他就像是这样，今天是圣诞节早晨。
It's just like a very exciting time.
这就像一个非常激动人心的时刻。
And it's almost like the energy of like, the worst thing already happened, who cares?
这几乎就像是最糟糕的事情已经发生了，谁在乎呢？
Like he had this kind of loose energy of like, I'm just, you know, reconnecting with Trudy, who was the girl from the Pineapple incident.
就像他有这种松散的能量一样，我只是，你知道，与特鲁迪重新建立联系，她是菠萝事件中的女孩。
And you, the other thing is bringing back Trudy starts to create like lore.
而你，另一件事是带回特鲁迪开始创造类似的传说。
Like we always talked Dave about the, how I met your mother lore and how you have these flashbacks and you fill in the kind of history and having her come back was really, I thought a great move.
就像我们总是谈论戴夫一样，我是如何遇见你母亲的传说，以及你如何有这些闪回，你填写了这样的历史，让她回来真的是，我认为这是一个伟大的举动。
Yeah, I love that.
是的，我喜欢那个。
Busy, Nutanica and Busy were just so much fun watching it, because I was on set obviously that week and I was just like thrilled.
Busy、Nutanica 和 Busy 观看它非常有趣，因为那周我显然在片场，我很兴奋。
Your chemistry with them is fantastic.
你和他们之间的化学反应非常棒。
And to your point, Josh, I feel like Ted, you know, what I really loved about it was that Ted was sort of in that hard shake the etch-a-sketch reset, you know, your moment in his life.
就你的观点而言，乔什，我感觉就像泰德，你知道，我真正喜欢的是泰德在那种艰难的摇动中，蚀刻草图重置，你知道，你在他生命中的时刻。
And getting to write this episode was such a privilege because I got to sort of explore the outer margins of what Ted thought was possible.
能够写这一集真是一种荣幸，因为我必须探索特德认为可能的外部边缘。
And I think he's regaining his confidence and I saw that confidence on full display.
我认为他正在恢复自信，我看到了这种自信的充分展现。
I rewatched the episode recently.
我最近重温了这一集。
I was like, I just love how charming you are.
我当时想，我只是喜欢你的魅力。
You know, you're charming.
你知道，你很有魅力。
Yeah.
是的。
But he was very charming in the show and it isn't brilliant.
但他在节目中非常有魅力，而且并不出彩。
I mean, even though, I think it was a Seinfeld episode about the same, the three of us, she is into it.
我的意思是，尽管如此，我认为这是一部关于我们三个人的宋飞正传，她很喜欢。
The thing is one where it was very much like, it was much more kind of brilliant.
这件事非常相似，而且更加辉煌。
It was a little, a little saltier.
有点，有点咸。
This was very much, this was very much like, well, we've always talked about this.
这非常非常像，嗯，我们一直在谈论这个。
We've always thought about it.
我们一直在思考这个问题。
Is this something that could actually occur?
这是实际可能发生的事情吗？
Oh my God, I can't believe it was like a new frontier.
天啊，我简直不敢相信这就像一个新的领域。
It was like, yeah.
就像是的。
I was just gonna say, it's like Lewis and Clark.
我只是想说，这就像刘易斯和克拉克。
It feels like Apollo 13.
感觉就像阿波罗13号一样。
And like, Marshall and Barney are like Houston, like they're just trying to like figure out how we're getting this space shuttle to wake them safely.
就像，马歇尔和巴尼就像休斯顿一样，他们只是想弄清楚我们如何让这架航天飞机安全地唤醒他们。
And it's like everyone appreciates the majesty of like the outer space that Ted is being shot into and wants to help it work out.
就好像每个人都欣赏泰德被射入的外太空的威严，并希望帮助它解决问题。
Yeah, the undiscovered country.
是的，未被发现的国家。
You know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that caused that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the hyper-fixed podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的超固定播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at hyperfixedpod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 hyperfixedpod.com 上都可以找到它。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
I do remember, though, reading it and being like, ah, this is a real gift for, I mean, one, there's so much fun stuff to play as an actor.
不过，我确实记得，读完这本书后，我想，啊，这是一份真正的礼物，我的意思是，作为一名演员，有很多有趣的东西可以扮演。
But also, I knew that Ted was being launched into territory that was like not his normal, like, you know, it's the very, like, why is this night different than all other nights?
而且，我知道特德正在进入一个不寻常的领域，就像，你知道，这就是为什么今晚与其他夜晚不同？
Like, and he, the casualness with, the casualness with which he goes down to the bar.
就像，他，漫不经心，漫不经心地去酒吧。
He's just, it's just a nut, you know, he suits up, which is like kind of funny, but he's just down there to shake off the cobwebs, you know.
他只是，这只是一个疯子，你知道，他穿了西装，这有点有趣，但他只是在那里摆脱蜘蛛网，你知道。
But the strangest nights of your life are generally those nights where you go and leave the door thinking this is nothing's gonna happen tonight.
但你一生中最奇怪的夜晚通常是那些你离开门时认为今晚不会发生任何事情的夜晚。
And it really isn't that pocket Josh to your point of like, this is Ted being single.
这确实不是你所说的口袋里的乔什，这是单身的特德。
This is really like the first two seasons of elementary mother were kind of not about that.
这真的就像《小学母亲》的前两季不是这样的。
Cause even when he's chasing after all these other women, it's cause he can't have Robin in season one.
因为即使他在追逐所有其他女人，这也是因为他在第一季中无法拥有罗宾。
In season two, he's with Robin.
在第二季中，他和罗宾在一起。
And the first two episodes of season three is really getting over the like nuclear explosion of that not working out and the fallout of that.
第三季的前两集确实克服了核爆炸那样的失败及其后果。
And this is the first one up, Dave's right.
这是第一个，戴夫是对的。
This was a shake up at the sketch.
这是草图上的一个变动。
Dave, you kind of like let off a new chapter here.
戴夫，你有点想在这里开启新的篇章。
And we knew the chapter would end.
我们知道这一章将会结束。
We knew that around episode 10, he meets another very serious new love interest in Sarah chalk.
我们知道在第 10 集左右，他遇到了另一位非常认真的新恋人莎拉·乔克。
And we said, for these like however many episodes that are seven or eight episodes, he's a guy.
我们说，对于这些七八集的剧集来说，他是一个男人。
He's a guy out on the town.
他是城里的一个人。
And what can we do?
我们能做什么？
What fun?
有什么好玩的？
What candy store can we walk into with that?
我们可以带着它走进哪家糖果店？
And this being the first big one like that is so genius and perfect because it's the ultimate candy store.
这是第一家这样的大型糖果店，它是如此天才和完美，因为它是终极糖果店。
Yeah, I just remember, you know, season three talking about that kind of nuclear fallout and the idea that this guy was now going to be kind of loose in about town and how do we explore that?
是的，我只记得，你知道，第三季谈论了那种核辐射，以及这个家伙现在在镇上无所事事的想法，我们如何探索这一点？
What's the most dynamic version of this guy?
这个家伙最有活力的版本是什么？
And I remember in the writer's room talking about the fact that I think that we called the term free-range Ted.
我记得在作家的房间里谈论过这样一个事实，我认为我们称这个词为自由放养的特德。
Like Ted was out and about and loose like free-range Ted and there was like no radio collar on him.
就像泰德在外面走来走去，像自由放养的泰德一样松散，而且他身上好像没有无线电项圈。
Nobody was tracking him.
没有人跟踪他。
You know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
He was out.
他出去了。
He was experiencing stuff.
他正在经历一些事情。
And he had the best possible ally, obviously in Barney, but also like, one thing I love about this episode too is that like Marshall and Lily are really supportive.
他有最好的盟友，显然是巴尼，但我也喜欢这一集的一件事是像马歇尔和莉莉这样的人真的很支持。
You know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
They're so into it.
他们非常热衷于它。
And Lily is just as supportive.
莉莉也同样支持。
She wants him to do it.
她希望他这么做。
It's hilarious that the one time Barney doesn't go out with Ted, and Ted isn't a suit, this happens.
有趣的是，有一次巴尼没有和泰德出去，而泰德又不穿西装，这种事就发生了。
It seems like the one missing piece is Barney should have been way, way more upset about that.
似乎缺少的一环是巴尼应该对此感到更加沮丧。
Like, second, how did this happen without me?
第二，如果没有我，这一切是怎么发生的？
He was supposed to be the facilitator of this kind of stuff.
他应该是这类事情的推动者。
He was supposed to be still there.
他应该还在那里。
Exactly.
确切地。
But I, the genius too, Dave, and I feel like this may have in your ad as well.
但我，也是天才，戴夫，我觉得这也可能出现在你的广告中。
The idea that Barney ultimately confesses the performance anxiety he felt and that we see two different versions, one's the ah, it slipped away and the other is no, I self-sabotage because of the crushing performance anxiety.
巴尼最终承认了他所感受到的表现焦虑，我们看到了两个不同的版本，一个是啊，它溜走了，另一个是不，我因为压倒性的表现焦虑而自我破坏。
That was so humanizing.
那真是太人性化了。
That was such a humanizing touch.
这真是一种人性化的接触。
That was such a genius little, that's part of what made, I think, the whole episode not too prescient because it really said, this is a lot.
这真是一个天才，我认为这就是整个情节不太有先见之明的部分原因，因为它真的说，这很多。
This would be a lot for any man.
这对于任何一个男人来说都是很多。
You're not the one over, you knock the wine over.
你不是那个倒下的人，你把酒打翻了。
You knock the wine over and the girlfriend's like, my boyfriend's gonna kill me.
你把酒打翻了，女朋友就会说，我男朋友会杀了我。
You have to get out of here.
你必须离开这里。
And it's like, well, so like, yeah, the fact that it was this anxiety.
就像，嗯，所以就像，是的，事实就是这种焦虑。
And it was like peeling the onion on Barney that I love too.
这就像给我也喜欢的巴尼剥洋葱一样。
It was like showing that that side of Barney that wasn't so incredibly bulletproof and it didn't have everything wired up.
这就像展示巴尼的那一面并不是那么防弹，也没有把所有东西都连接起来。
I mean, just the enormity of this, being able to sort of kind of bitch slap any man's ego.
我的意思是，这件事的严重性在于，能够对任何男人的自尊心进行打击。
you're sort of like, I can't, how do I, what am I doing?
你有点像，我不能，我该怎么办，我在做什么？
Is this, it's like almost an existential crisis.
这是吗，这几乎就像一场生存危机。
You're like, what, how am I, you know, it's like, I love all that, you know.
你就像，我怎么样，你知道，就像，我喜欢这一切，你知道。
Well, it also, I think that how I met your mother was always a trailblazer in terms of like pulling back the curtain on like male vulnerability, especially around matters of sex and love, right?
嗯，我也认为我如何认识你母亲一直是一个开拓者，就像拉开了男性脆弱性的帷幕，尤其是在性和爱的问题上，对吧？
Like, you think, I mean, even Barney, who has so much bravado, we always talk about that, you had to kind of give him both come up But also reveal the vulnerability underneath him, you know, and this is that's a great kind of reversal I wanted to ask where the term tricycle came from because it felt very master of his domain kind of, you know It felt like you know, I think I was you Dave.
就像，你想，我的意思是，即使是巴尼，他非常虚张声势，我们总是谈论这一点，你必须让他两者都出现，但也要揭示他内心的脆弱，你知道，这是一个伟大的逆转，我想问“三轮车”这个词是从哪里来的，因为它感觉像是他领域的主人，你知道，感觉就像你知道的，我想我是你戴夫。
I don't I think you can't with that.
我不认为你不能这样做。
Yeah, that was me I was sort of like ride the tricycle I was sort of thinking about in terms of like you talk about male vulnerability You know and male sexuality and and like gender roles and the whole thing and all that sort of being subtly challenged in this episode like, you know, being unpacked.
是的，那就是我，我有点像骑三轮车，我在想，就像你谈论男性的脆弱性，你知道，男性性行为，性别角色，整个事情以及所有这些在这一集里受到微妙的挑战，比如，你知道，被打开行李。
And they're the ones who are sort of deciding whether or not it'll happen.
他们是决定这是否会发生的人。
Like, he has really no agency other than to sort of get over himself and kind of enjoy this invitation that he's being afforded.
就像，除了克服自己并享受他所收到的邀请之外，他真的没有其他办法。
In some ways, the question of consent is will Ted consent to them.
在某些方面，同意的问题是泰德是否同意他们。
It's not the women.
这不是女人。
The women are all in it.
女人都在其中。
The women are driving it.
妇女们正在驾驶它。
It's the women are driving this and the whole thing is it's Ted and Ted's ego and Ted's uncertainty and where he's been with Rob and I think that's all implicit in the episode and Barney sort of bravado you know was sort of undercut and he then that second flashback reveals that he wasn't able to to follow through so it's really about kind of fragility and agency and how you know this guy wasn't driving it he was actually invited into this to ride the tricycle he was invited to the of the tricycle.
这是女人在推动这一切，整件事是泰德和泰德的自我和泰德的不确定性以及他和罗布在一起的地方，我认为这一切都隐含在这一集中，巴尼的虚张声势你知道有点被削弱了，然后他的第二个闪回揭示了他无法坚持到底，所以这实际上是关于一种脆弱性和代理性，以及你如何知道这个人不是在驾驶它，他实际上是被邀请参加这件事的三轮车 他被邀请参加了三轮车的活动。
Yeah, and you couldn't handle the pressure.
是的，你无法承受压力。
Josh, that moment where your performance sound like, I'll get your coats and then you go in your dad's room.
乔希，那一刻你的表演听起来就像是，我去拿你的外套，然后你去你爸爸的房间。
It's like, why did they say that?
就像，他们为什么这么说？
It's just like, it's such a funny like meltdown moment.
就像，这是一个非常有趣的崩溃时刻。
And the fact that Barney is sympathetic to it and reveals what he reveals there, to me that's when the episode just like becomes a classic him-yem.
事实上，巴尼对此表示同情，并透露了他在那里透露的内容，对我来说，这就是这一集成为经典的他-耶姆的时候。
Yeah.
是的。
That's so surprising and weird and great.
这真是令人惊讶、奇怪、伟大。
Well, it also, there's another flip with Barney earlier on, which is, wait, how are you gonna get this first?
好吧，还有，早些时候与巴尼还有另一个翻转，那就是，等等，你要如何先得到这个？
And he's angry, but then he becomes, he gives another like, grapes of wrath speech where he gives him his friend.
他很生气，但后来他变得，他给了他的朋友另一个类似愤怒的葡萄的演讲。
For his friend, he like, Barney, it is very interesting.
对于他喜欢的朋友巴尼来说，这很有趣。
Like his loyalty to his friends and especially Ted actually does trump his need to get laid.
就像他对朋友的忠诚，尤其是对泰德的忠诚，实际上确实胜过了他上床的需要。
Like he would choose his friend over that.
就像他会选择他的朋友一样。
It's more like he's interested in the story.
看来他对这个故事很感兴趣。
He just wants to amass great stories.
他只是想积累精彩的故事。
Yeah.
是的。
And he sets his ego aside.
他把自我放在一边。
He sets his ego aside to help his friend.
他放下自我来帮助他的朋友。
And it was like, there's a lot of, you know, revelatory moments between these characters in that bedroom, especially when they're all talking about, and I just love the fact that Marshall and William are part of it.
就好像，卧室里的这些角色之间有很多，你知道的，启示性的时刻，尤其是当他们都在谈论的时候，我只是喜欢马歇尔和威廉参与其中的事实。
And I remember that being, you know, I also, Michael Fran's noise is off really inspired me in this episode.
我记得，你知道，我也认为迈克尔·弗兰的噪音在这一集里确实给了我启发。
I really want to be real-time.
我真的想要实时。
I really want that slamming doors thing to be happening.
我真的希望关门的事情发生。
It's slamming doors, yeah.
这是在关门，是的。
It is.
这是。
It has that hells-a-popping, like, first energy.
它具有那种地狱般的第一能量。
It's so, like, electric and Johnson.
就像电动和约翰逊一样。
I feel like your whole, your whole energy at the beginning of season three, that you have a very electric energy in the full first few episodes of this season.
我觉得你在第三季开始时的全部能量，在本季的前几集中你都充满了能量。
It's very exciting.
这非常令人兴奋。
Jordana commented on this too, like, I was pretty loose.
乔丹娜也对​​此发表了评论，比如，我很宽松。
Like, bodily, I felt like, and I had, we had talked about this day, but I had just come back from doing a lot of ayahuasca in the jungle.
就像，身体上，我感觉，而且我确实，我们谈论过这一天，但我刚刚在丛林里做了很多死藤水回来。
I remember that.
我记得。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
Because I had an inability to not talk about it with everyone.
因为我无法不和大家谈论这件事。
Like, I was like, you wanna talk about this?
就像，我当时想，你想谈谈这个吗？
or waiting for a scene to be lit.
或等待场景被点亮。
But I felt like I was really inhabiting my body in a different way.
但我觉得我真的以一种不同的方式居住在我的身体里。
The first two seasons, Ted was a little more of a head moving around.
前两个赛季，泰德有点喜欢四处走动。
He was very in his head.
他很在意。
And they even commented on that.
他们甚至对此发表了评论。
Like the overthinky, right?
就像想太多一样，对吧？
There was something about the looseness and the embodied quality of him.
他身上有一种松散的气质和内在的品质。
And even his kind of, there were a lot of sharp left turns, like literally physically, like moving in and out of the rooms and trying to, you know, just almost like get his body and his mind to cooperate because they were so, they were going in a hundred different directions.
即使是他的那种，也有很多急速的左转，就像字面意义上的身体上的那样，就像进出房间一样，试图，你知道，就像让他的身体和思想合作，因为他们是如此，他们正朝着一百个不同的方向前进。
There's like a young Pacino happening a little bit.
就像年轻的帕西诺一样。
That's right, that's right.
没错，没错。
Panic and Needle Park kind of thing going on.
恐慌和针公园之类的事情正在发生。
Yeah, he was twitching, yeah.
是的，他在抽搐，是的。
But it's like so high stakes.
但这就像赌注如此之高。
It's so high stakes.
这是如此高的风险。
It's in real time, mostly.
大部分是实时的。
It's you're very in, it is very edge of your seat.
这是你非常投入的，它非常靠近你的座位。
I watch this with my wife and you're like on the edge of your seat.
我和我妻子一起看这个，你就像坐在座位边上一样。
and just like, I really felt her like, oh, it's gonna happen.
就像，我真的感觉到她，哦，这会发生。
She hadn't seen this episode in 20 years.
她已经有二十年没有看过这一集了。
And she was very, very into it.
她非常非常喜欢它。
The way it's constructed, Dave, is you recruit the audience into TEDs.
戴夫，它的构建方式是吸引观众参加 TED。
The mission control in TEDs bedroom is the audience also.
TED 卧室里的任务控制中心也是观众。
That's the audience.
这就是观众。
You know, everyone is kind of like, that's what I mean about it being wholesome.
你知道，每个人都有点像，这就是我所说的健康的意思。
Like, what other show do you watch?
比如，你还看什么节目？
Where pretty much 100% of the audience is cheering for the guy to get us recently.
几乎 100% 的观众都在为这个家伙最近抓住我们而欢呼。
Like, that's a really, that's a feat.
就像，这真的是一项壮举。
No, but honestly, and you know, just to say this, sweet Josh, like I don't know whether actor, who could pull it off because you have and you had at the time and you still have this inherent likability, you know what I'm saying?
不，但说实话，你知道，只是这么说，亲爱的乔什，就像我不知道演员是否可以成功，因为你曾经并且当时曾经做过，而且你仍然具有这种固有的可爱性，你知道我在说什么吗？
This sort of charm and openness so that like, when you're, when I was writing it, I'm thinking like a certain other, you know, actors who would seem disingenuous that you would expect people to root for this to happen.
这种魅力和开放性，就像，当你，当我写它时，我像其他某个演员一样思考，你知道，那些看起来不诚实的演员，你会期望人们支持这种情况的发生。
But you know, first of all, the women were 100% on board.
但你知道，首先，女性 100% 都参与其中。
And secondly, the fact that you were sorting through all the emotions and insecurities and challenges, and you could see it in your body, you were looser with your body, but you were finding a whole nother rhythm for the character as he entered this new chapter.
其次，事实上你正在整理所有的情绪、不安全感和挑战，你可以在你的身体上看到它，你的身体更加放松，但当他进入这个新的篇章时，你为角色找到了一种完全不同的节奏。
I don't know, either actor who could have pulled that off because it was just like, like you're saying, like what is the, and what other show could you, would you have this dynamic?
我不知道，任何一个演员都可以做到这一点，因为就像你说的那样，就像什么是，还有什么其他节目可以，你会有这种动力吗？
It could have been a total fail in the wrong hands and lesser hands.
如果落入坏人或较弱者之手，这可能会彻底失败。
It could have been gross and unrootable and uncomfortable.
它可能是粗俗的、无法根除的、不舒服的。
And it doesn't play that way, doesn't play that way at all.
但它不是那样玩的，根本不是那样玩的。
It didn't play the way then, it doesn't play that way now.
那时不是这样玩的，现在也不是这样玩的。
It really is a great performance.
这确实是一场很棒的表演。
This is a great tad episode.
这是一个很棒的插曲。
Yeah, that really is.
是的，确实是这样。
Appreciate all that, and that's so nice to hear.
感谢这一切，很高兴听到这些。
You know, because we tend to dip into literature and philosophy on it, I have a funny deep cut literature reference that I wanted to bring to you guys.
你知道，因为我们倾向于深入研究文学和哲学，所以我想给你们带来一个有趣的深刻的文学参考。
Yes.
是的。
When Trudy and, what was Busy's character's name?
当 Trudy 和 Busy 的角色叫什么名字？
Rachel.
雷切尔。
When they see each other again, they kind of like fall back into this old dynamic that they had in college, which was like, part obsessed with each other, but also competitive with each other, and the old grudges are kind of like coming out, but also like, and it reminded me of a Nathaniel Hawthorne story that I read in college called Dr. Heidegger's Experiment.
当他们再次见面时，他们有点像又回到了大学时的旧动态，就像，彼此部分着迷，但也互相竞争，旧的恩怨有点像出来，但也像，这让我想起了我在大学读过的纳撒尼尔·霍桑的故事，名为海德格尔博士的实验。
Do any of you guys know this?
你们有人知道这个吗？
Nathaniel Hawthorne's story?
纳撒尼尔霍桑的故事？
So Dr. Heidegger, he gathers these four older people.
海德格尔博士，他聚集了这四个老年人。
I think it's one woman and three men, and they're older, they're senior citizens, let's say.
我认为是一名女性和三名男性，他们年龄较大，可以说是老年人。
And he's discovered the literal fountain of youth, and they talk about how they were all so foolish, because I think the three men were all in love with the woman, and they all behaved abysmally, and he gives them this fountain of youth, and they say, oh, we would never behave that way, like we've learned.
他发现了真正的青春之泉，他们谈论他们如何如此愚蠢，因为我认为这三个男人都爱上了那个女人，他们的行为都很糟糕，他给了他们这个青春之泉，他们说，哦，我们永远不会那样做，就像我们学到的那样。
And then they get reverted back to there, and they immediately become who they were, right?
然后他们又回到了那里，他们立刻就变成了原来的样子，对吗？
And for some reason, like seeing Trudy and Rachel together reminds me of this within a Hawthorne story where certain people, you know, they say that birth order is kind of a myth, except when you're with your family of origin.
出于某种原因，就像看到特鲁迪和雷切尔在一起让我想起了霍桑故事中的这一点，其中某些人，你知道，他们说出生顺序是一种神话，除非你和你的原生家庭在一起。
Like, you're not a middle child in the world, but when you get back with your family of origin, you become that kind of thing.
就像，你不是世界上的中间孩子，但是当你回到原生家庭时，你就变成了那样的东西。
And I think there are those deeply grooved, almost elastic feelings, like how Robin was with the James Vanderbeek character.
我认为有一些深刻的、几乎有弹性的感觉，就像罗宾对詹姆斯·范德贝克这个角色的感受一样。
You know, like, you snap back to this old way of being.
你知道，就像，你很快又回到了原来的生活方式。
And I thought that was the episode of Revertego, where we coined a term for exactly what you're saying.
我以为那是 Revertego 的一集，我们为你所说的创造了一个术语。
I wish we'd reference Hawthorne in a moment.
我希望我们稍后能提到霍桑。
I know we should go back in the head.
我知道我们应该回到头脑中。
That would have been a really smart.
那真是太聪明了。
But I could feel, I could feel, Craig, that you guys were the belts, the tricycle.
但我能感觉到，我能感觉到，克雷格，你们就是腰带，三轮车。
I mean, there were certain things that you guys were really trying to like coin some culturally like.
我的意思是，有些东西你们真的很想在文化上创造一些喜欢的东西。
We were sweatily just groping for catchphases all over this episode.
我们满头大汗地摸索着这一集的所有关键点。
I'm not all of them stuck, but a lot of them did, you know.
我并不是所有人都被困住了，但很多人都被困住了，你知道。
The belt and the tricycle stuck.
皮带和三轮车卡住了。
That was also the season.
那个季节也是如此。
The season three is also the season of the one minute date, right?
第三季也是一分钟约会的季节，对吧？
Yeah, yeah, two minute data.
是的，是的，两分钟的数据。
Yeah, I mean, it's like 10 episodes after this, basically.
是的，我的意思是，基本上，这之后大概有10集。
I remember pitching, I remember pitching it out with you in your office.
我记得推销，我记得在你的办公室里和你一起推销它。
Yes.
是的。
And the whole thing.
以及整个事情。
Every bit of that.
每一点。
Yes.
是的。
Dave is talking about physicality and looseness to you.
戴夫正在向你谈论身体和放松。
Dave is a very physical pitcher.
戴夫是一位身体素质非常出色的投手。
Dave needs the whole room.
戴夫需要整个房间。
It's just picture Robin Williams, right?
这只是罗宾·威廉姆斯的照片，对吧？
Well, a lot of that's a lot of Columbia trained lawyers, isn't that.
嗯，其中很多都是哥伦比亚大学训练有素的律师，不是吗。
Yeah.
是的。
You wouldn't get in the body.
你不会进入身体。
Just bury in their body, bury in their body, very willing to go there with the improv.
就埋在他们的身体里，埋在他们的身体里，非常愿意去那里即兴表演。
But no.
但没有。
this specific episode, one of the things I loved so much about it was the urgency, the doubt, the romance.
在这个特定的情节中，我非常喜欢它的原因之一就是它的紧迫感、疑问和浪漫。
You know what's funny Dave, if we call out some, we like to call out things that do look a little dated.
你知道什么很有趣，戴夫，如果我们指出一些，我们喜欢指出那些看起来确实有点过时的东西。
I think the whole episode holds up really well.
我认为整个情节都非常好。
What's really funny is Barney's way to stab us, Tasha, is breaking a Wilco CD.
真正有趣的是巴尼刺伤我们的方式，塔莎，是打破威尔科的CD。
There's a lot of fun, there's a lot of fun, things like that, like, oh my god, Wilco, what are you doing with the Wilco CD?
有很多乐趣，有很多乐趣，诸如此类的事情，比如，天哪，Wilco，你用 Wilco CD 做什么？
This is the golden key to a three way.
这是三通的金钥匙。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you.
而这个老人，他必须让我爱上你。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now, commercials.
现在，广告。
End of commercials?
广告完结了？
Back to show.
返回展示。
But also, you could have chosen a band that aged less well.
而且，你也可以选择一支年龄不太大的乐队。
Like, Wilco is still- Wilco did it.
就像，威尔科仍然是——威尔科做到了。
No, no, no, Wilco's.
不，不，不，威尔科的。
By the way, I fucking loved Wilco.
顺便说一句，我太爱威尔科了。
It could have been Stitch.
可能是史迪奇。
I love Oco.
我爱奥科。
I just love the idea that the conceit is that everyone goes with it like this is this is the way This is gonna happen.
我只是喜欢这样的想法，即每个人都遵循它，就像这就是这将要发生的方式一样。
We've got to listen to this will go see once that seat He's broken all is lost.
我们必须听听这个，一旦他打破了那个座位，一切都消失了，我们就去看看。
It was just such a funny Anything that I start struck me was the wheat the wheat tennis Yes, and then the implausible thing I'm slightly implausible thing and but actually now that we've talked about it today with you guys I'm like actually this is plausible because Marshall and Lily are so on board with Ted, and that's part of it.
这真是太有趣了，我开始打动我的是小麦，小麦网球，是的，然后是难以置信的事情，我有点难以置信，但实际上，现在我们今天和你们谈论了这件事，我觉得这实际上是合理的，因为马歇尔和莉莉与特德如此合作，这就是其中的一部分。
You're right, Dave, that is part of what's great, that's part of what makes Marshall and Lily great, that's interesting in this episode.
你是对的，戴夫，这就是伟大的一部分，这就是马歇尔和莉莉伟大的一部分，这一集很有趣。
There's no naysayer, there's no tisks, tisks, tisks.
没有反对者，没有任何问题、问题、问题。
But I will say, it is funny how willing Lily is to allow a three way to happen on her bed.
但我要说的是，有趣的是莉莉多么愿意允许三人在她的床上发生。
She's like, yeah, just go use my, there's no discussion, there's no debate.
她说，是的，就用我的吧，没有讨论，没有辩论。
I know, but I love that because she's so gay and it's one of the things I really want to do with the episode.
我知道，但我喜欢这一点，因为她是如此同性恋，这是我真正想做的事情之一。
Because it's like, exactly what you're saying, dude, It's like, had we ever put any judgment in this?
因为这就像，正如你所说的，伙计，这就像，我们曾经对此做出过任何判断吗？
Go to space my bedroom.
去我的卧室太空吧。
Go to just get stuff everywhere.
到处去拿东西。
Do it.
做吧。
It's sort of like, but it means she's in it for the experiential knowledge.
有点像，但这意味着她参与其中是为了获得经验知识。
There's no judgment.
没有判断力。
You got a lover.
你有一个情人了。
And she knows the Ted needs it.
她知道特德需要它。
She knows the Ted needs it.
She knows the Ted needs to shake the edges.
她知道特德需要摆脱困境。
You know, that's why she endorses it.
你知道，这就是她赞同的原因。
You know, it's not only Ted and Barney that are creating this lore and this history as they go, everyone on some level recognizes when a momentous event is happening and they want it to happen.
你知道，不仅仅是泰德和巴尼创造了这个传说和历史，每个人都在某种程度上认识到重大事件正在发生，并且他们希望它发生。
We'll talk about this for years.
我们将讨论这个问题很多年。
If this happens, this is winning the world, this is the belt, it's the fucking belt.
如果发生这种情况，这就是赢得世界，这就是腰带，这就是他妈的腰带。
I mean, it was genius that we actually, I think the belt might have been Carter's pitch.
我的意思是，这是天才，我们实际上，我认为腰带可能是卡特的投球。
The belt is such a fun year.
腰带真是有趣的一年。
An idea that it's like literally face, I think a WWE wrestling champion belt.
一个想法，它就像字面上的脸，我认为是 WWE 摔跤冠军腰带。
I think that's what it was.
我想就是这样。
I think we literally got like one of those, like a replica, the crown for sleeping with the days of our lives.
我认为我们确实得到了其中之一，就像一个复制品，是与我们生命中的日子一起睡觉的王冠。
The crown coming out of Barney's head was so funny.
从巴尼头上掉下来的王冠真是太有趣了。
And by the way, just to name check Robin's story, It also was Robin gets to go be single for the first time on Twitter by 10.
顺便说一下，罗宾的故事是这样的：罗宾 10 岁时在 Twitter 上首次成为单身。
Gail, Robin's like Enrique Iglesias boyfriend.
盖尔、罗宾就像恩里克·伊格莱西亚的男朋友。
That was a reaction to Ted that affected her and Ted.
这是对泰德的反应，影响了她和泰德。
This was her back out on the market.
这是她重返市场。
And that was a pretty funny fucking storyline too.
这也是一个非常有趣的故事情节。
The theme story was great, not shaving her legs.
主题故事很棒，没有刮腿毛。
Not shaving legs, really funny.
不刮腿毛，真搞笑。
The using the butter and then falling and literally knocking herself unconscious was so funny.
使用黄油然后摔倒并让自己失去知觉真是太有趣了。
The ending line of this episode is something like, I'm bleeding from my head, I'm going down again.
这一集的结尾是这样的，我的头在流血，我又要倒下去了。
and she just falls on the floor.
她就倒在了地板上。
She's like in dire medical shape as this episode.
正如这一集，她的健康状况非常糟糕。
But also there's something so, almost like comedian Del Arte about that whole idea is just one idea.
但也有一些事情，就像喜剧演员德尔·阿特所说的那样，整个想法只是一个想法。
She didn't shave her legs so she'll, what does she say if I don't shave, I must behave?
她没有刮腿毛，所以她会，她说如果我不刮毛，我必须表现得好？
If I don't shave, I must behave.
如果我不刮胡子，我就必须表现得规矩。
And then I like Johnny Cochrane.
然后我喜欢约翰尼·科克伦。
Guys just want to get on the green.
伙计们只想上果岭。
They don't care about going through the rough.
他们不在乎经历困难。
Exactly, yeah.
没错，是的。
That was great.
那很棒。
But there's something so simple about like, this is what I like, Dave.
但有一些很简单的事情，比如，这就是我喜欢的，戴夫。
I always like thinking about a comedy writer's room, which I really, you know, I was on the other side of the aisle there.
我总是喜欢想象喜剧作家的房间，我真的，你知道，我就在过道的另一边。
I wasn't in the room.
我不在房间里。
I maybe stopped by for a visit once or twice.
我可能会停下来参观一两次。
But I just love the idea, you know, Robin is trying to, she doesn't shave her legs, but then she's super attracted to the guy and she has to get this hair off her legs.
但我就是喜欢这个主意，你知道，罗宾正在努力，她没有刮腿毛，但她对这个家伙非常感兴趣，她必须把腿上的毛去掉。
Like it's so simple, but you can do a whole big, juicy B story on it, you know?
就好像它很简单，但你可以用它写一个完整的、有趣的 B 故事，你知道吗？
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
If you want to, and the cast, the great thing about the cast was you guys, tone.
如果你愿意的话，还有演员们，演员们最棒的地方就是你们，语气。
And Carter and Craig, you built this brilliant show, this brilliant machine.
卡特和克雷格，你们打造了这场精彩的表演，这台精彩的机器。
And so the tone that you baked into the pilot, and that was absolutely refined, amplified and refined over seasons one and two, allowed for that.
因此，你在试播集中融入的基调，以及在第一季和第二季中绝对经过提炼、放大和提炼的基调，允许做到这一点。
Like certain shows would not allow for that level of like, what I've come to understand, and I learned about what I was writing a holdover is an Alexander Payne, and I've leaned it because I'm a very verbal person, very verbal writer, was to allow things to breathe and allow physicality to really roost.
就像某些节目不允许这种程度的喜欢一样，我逐渐明白，我了解到我正在写的保留是亚历山大·佩恩的作品，我已经倾向于它，因为我是一个非常善于言辞的人，非常言辞的作家，是让事物呼吸，让身体真正栖息。
And I feel like that's one of those episodes, that's one of those B stories where it was simple enough that you understood the drive, the drive was credible, and the actions she took were tightened 10 to 15%, but you got all of it.
我觉得那是其中一集，这是 B 级故事之一，故事很简单，你可以理解这种驱动力，这种驱动力是可信的，她采取的行动收紧了 10% 到 15%，但你得到了全部。
And it allowed Kobe to sort of like air it out a little bit.
这让科比可以稍微宣泄一下。
And that's what I really love.
这就是我真正喜欢的。
You know, I mean, I really, I love writing physical comedy.
你知道，我的意思是，我真的很喜欢写肢体喜剧。
I love it when actors, the whole cast is brain, everybody could do the physical comedy.
我喜欢演员，整个演员都是大脑，每个人都可以表演肢体喜剧。
And I felt like there was some like commentary, physical comedy and both stories in this episode.
我觉得这一集中有一些评论、肢体喜剧和两个故事。
Yeah, they're both very physical stories.
是的，它们都是非常真实的故事。
They're like visceral physical stories.
它们就像发自内心的身体故事。
Yeah, it's almost like the, like we, we, we, we kind of want to get like highfalutin about dating, but it's like we have these bodies, you know, but we have these bodies that like sprout hair and like make noises and like we're navigating all of that, you know, especially when you the first time of like revealing your body with someone, it's very high stakes, right?
是的，这几乎就像，就像我们，我们，我们，我们有点想在约会时夸夸其谈，但这就像我们有这些身体，你知道，但我们有这些身体，喜欢发芽，喜欢发出声音，就像我们正在经历这一切，你知道，尤其是当你第一次喜欢向某人展示你的身体时，这是非常高的风险，对吧？
And like both the theme of both stories and where is expectation versus reality, right?
就像两个故事的主题一样，期望与现实之间的差距在哪里，对吗？
Yeah, like, you know, what is the reality?
是的，就像，你知道，现实是什么？
What is the expectation?
期望是什么？
The third wheel certainly is that and also like shaving your legs into actually bed this guy in the first day.
第三轮当然就是这样，而且就像第一天把你的腿剃到床上一样。
It's like it's kind of a tremendous dynamic, you know?
这就像一种巨大的动力，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And there's like a really simple like impediment or obstacle to success in both stories or a couple of impediments and obstacles.
这两个故事中都有一个非常简单的成功障碍或障碍，或者几个障碍和障碍。
They're both it's funny.
他俩都挺搞笑的
It's one crazy night out.
这是一个疯狂的夜晚。
It's one crazy night out, it's like the pilot, it mirrors the DNA of the pilot, and it really is.
这是一个疯狂的夜晚，就像飞行员一样，它反映了飞行员的 DNA，而且确实如此。
It did feel like you were coming in, Dave, with a good fresh eyes on what works about the show.
戴夫，确实感觉你进来了，对这部剧的运作方式有了全新的认识。
You hadn't been on the first two seasons, and you came in and you were like, let's light a fuse and let it go.
你没有参加前两季，当你进来的时候，你就像，让我们点燃导火线然后放手吧。
Was there some benefit to that, Dave, do you think that you watched the first two seasons as a fan of the show?
戴夫，你认为你作为该剧的粉丝观看了前两季吗？
Absolutely.
绝对地。
I fell in love with Carne and Craig when we worked together on American Dad.
当卡恩和克雷格在《美国爸爸》中合作时，我爱上了他们。
I just like you know that was a killer room and it was like these guys were it was amazing room I mean in Austria con you me We're we're filling Chris.
我就像你知道那是一个杀手房间，就像这些人一样，这是一个令人惊叹的房间，我的意思是在奥地利，骗你我，我们正在填补克里斯。
We're Miller and Lord and no no we had them on season one of him Yes, he's one that's right.
我们是米勒和洛德，不不，我们在他的第一季就有了他们，是的，他是对的。
We had they are there was there was a lot of heavy hitters a Chris McKenna on Yeah, the McCaller brothers.
我们在那里有很多重量级人物，克里斯·麦肯纳（Chris McKenna）在《是的，麦卡勒兄弟》中。
They're like those they just talked about him great writing staff Yeah, but I remember joining being being huge fans and you know we both are respective pilots went the same year And you know being invited to join I was so honored and and when I got on I had such a such a deep reservoir of love and affection for for Carter and Craig And having watched the show I'm like If they're breaking up, I remember thinking to myself like what an opportunity to just sort of like like just rockets led This this fucking thing like rockets led it Yeah, let's just get on the rocket said and have as much fun as we can with this guy before he falls in with Stella Sizmore Which I remember that I remember that came from It will be never zin-min to be a slates difference from Jonathan's is more a doctor See that the company the chemical feel the chemical I'm saying they're not there anymore I feel like even as recently on the subway you'd be on some really old train that hadn't updated there'd still be a doctor's Is more on there more.
他们就像他们刚刚谈论的那些伟大的写作人员是的，但我记得加入时是巨大的粉丝，你知道我们都是同一年的飞行员，你知道被邀请加入我感到非常荣幸，当我加入时，我对卡特和克雷格怀有如此深厚的爱和感情，看完节目我想如果他们分手了，我记得自己心里想，这是一个多么好的机会，就像火箭领导的这他妈的东西就像火箭领导的那样是的，我们就上火箭说，在他和斯特拉·西兹莫尔坠入爱河之前，尽可能多地和这个家伙一起玩吧，我记得我记得那来自于与乔纳森的石板不同，这永远不会是津民，更多的是一个医生看到公司的化学物质感觉化学物质我说他们不再存在了我觉得即使最近在地铁上你会在一些没有更新的非常旧的火车上仍然会有一个医生是还有更多。
Yeah from 1992 New York City local celebrity that the whole tramp stamp came from an after-and-a-ice band, Stephen Webber's house.
是的，从 1992 年纽约当地的名人来看，整张流浪汉邮票都来自一支 After and a Ice 乐队，史蒂芬·韦伯 (Stephen Webber) 的家。
Wait, it was Dave, tell that story real quick.
等等，是戴夫，快点讲这个故事。
Thank you for bringing that up.
谢谢你提出这个问题。
Because we just, two episodes earlier, we talked about, we did that episode, and I said, I probably told it wrong on the podcast, because I said, I know this was from Dave.
因为我们只是，前两集，我们谈论过，我们做了那一集，我说，我可能在播客上说错了，因为我说，我知道这是戴夫的。
I did some Dave having said.
戴夫说过的话我做了一些。
And I know, my memory of it was that you had not so long before that episode, seen somebody jog by with shirtless.
我知道，我的记忆是在那一集之前不久，你看到有人光着膀子慢跑着。
And if I'm getting this wrong, tell me.
如果我弄错了，请告诉我。
This is wrong, this is wrong.
这是错误的，这是错误的。
As they passed by, you saw them.
当他们经过时，你看到了他们。
Did I invent that part?
那部分是我发明的吗？
You invented that part.
你发明了那部分。
We're actually having with this.
我们实际上正在接受这个。
My kids and my wife and I, we went to school at the Willows and we went up to Stephen Weber's house on a Sunday afternoon to go swimming.
我和我的孩子、妻子和我在柳树学校上学，周日下午我们去史蒂芬·韦伯家去游泳。
He could get a pool.
他可以得到一个游泳池。
Yeah, Stephen Weber.
是的，史蒂芬·韦伯。
Stephen Weber.
史蒂芬·韦伯.
He's great, we went to Stephen's house and I for whatever reason didn't bring my suit.
他很棒，我们去了斯蒂芬家，但我出于某种原因没有带西装。
He's like, I'll borrow a suit and I have a thing where I feel like I actually have swimsuits at my house that I give to people because no man should be obliged to wear another man swimsuit, because you don't want the boys cradled in somebody else's mesh, it's just weird, right?
他说，我会借一套泳衣，我觉得我家里实际上有泳衣，我会把泳衣送给人们，因为没有男人应该被迫穿另一个男人泳衣，因为你不希望男孩们躺在别人的网眼里，这很奇怪，对吧？
So I actually have swimsuits that I keep, I buy them on sale the other season.
所以我实际上有保留的泳衣，我在其他季节打折时买的。
Anyway, he always means swimsuit, I pass, I'm just gonna say, I'll drink my beer and you can go swimming.
无论如何，他总是指的是泳衣，我通过了，我只是想说，我会喝我的啤酒，你可以去游泳。
So he takes off his shirt and he turns around and Steven Weber has a tramp stamp.
于是他脱掉衬衫，转过身，史蒂文·韦伯身上盖上了流浪汉的印记。
How did I forget that it's from Steven Weber?
我怎么忘了这是史蒂文·韦伯写的？
I didn't say so he turns around and I'm like, I just don't want you just blew my fucking mind.
我没有这么说，所以他转过身来，我想，我只是不想让你让我大吃一惊。
Were they wings?
它们是翅膀吗？
I don't know, maybe it wasn't.
我不知道，也许不是。
It was like a tribal tattoo.
这就像一个部落纹身。
It was a tribal tattoo.
这是一个部落纹身。
Okay, so we invented butterfly and I invented the origin story.
好吧，我们发明了蝴蝶，我发明了起源故事。
I knew you saw somebody that had it.
我知道你看到有人拥有它。
How the fuck I could have forget that it was Steve in the room.
我他妈的怎么会忘记房间里的是史蒂夫呢。
I went into the room on Monday.
星期一我走进房间。
I said, remember going in, do you remember this?
我说，记得进去，你还记得这个吗？
Do you remember this, Craig?
你还记得这个吗，克雷格？
Well, clearly I don't remember it well enough because I haven't.
嗯，显然我记得不太清楚，因为我没有。
I was like, guys, you're not going to believe what I saw.
我当时想，伙计们，你们不会相信我所看到的。
Yeah.
是的。
I was like, and they were like, oh my God, Ted has to have a transtance.
我当时想，他们也想，天啊，特德必须有一个恍惚状态。
That's what it came for.
这就是它的目的。
I mean, I knew it was from you.
我的意思是，我知道这是你发来的。
I knew it was from you seeing somebody with it, but then I blacked out, apparently the rest, or maybe at the time you didn't tell us what was Steven Weber you must have.
我知道那是因为你看到某人拥有它，但后来我眼前一黑，显然是其余的，或者也许当时你没有告诉我们你必须拥有什么是史蒂文·韦伯。
Yeah, I must have just, I was like, were you protecting Steven Weber's identity then?
是的，我当时想，你当时是在保护史蒂文·韦伯的身份吗？
But now you're just throwing him out of them.
但现在你只是把他赶出了他们。
Look, this will be good for everybody.
听着，这对每个人都有好处。
It had to come out.
它必须出来。
It's funny that your memory of it is so much more anodyne than the real story.
有趣的是，你对它的记忆比真实的故事要镇痛得多。
Like you were just like, just a passerby, like a jogger.
就像你只是一个路人，就像一个慢跑者。
I know, I made this story so much worse in my shitty memory of it, that's terrible.
我知道，在我糟糕的记忆中，我把这个故事变得更糟了，太可怕了。
I just remember going to the room and going like, and it was such a great room.
我只记得走进房间，那是一个非常棒的房间。
It was just, I remember going, like, because people were just pitching stuff from their lives and stuff they picked up.
我记得去的时候，因为人们只是在推销他们生活中的东西和他们捡到的东西。
And I remember all of us going like, yeah, Ted has had a tramp stamp.
我记得我们所有人都想，是的，特德有一个流浪汉的印记。
It's like, you give me a threesome, but you also give me a tramp stamp, like you give it, and you take it forward.
就像，你给了我一个三人组，但你也给了我一个流浪者邮票，就像你给它一样，然后你把它向前推进。
That's life, you know what I'm saying?
这就是生活，你知道我在说什么吗？
It's life, you got it.
这就是生活，你明白了。
You know, I still, I have people reach out to me.
你知道，我仍然有人联系我。
People, you know, there's certain people that wanna know like, what was the pineapple?
人们，你知道，有些人想知道，菠萝是什么？
Like there's people that wanna know these mysteries.
就像有人想知道这些奥秘一样。
And a lot of, I've been approached a lot of times, people say, did you get the belt?
很多次，人们问过我很多次，你拿到腰带了吗？
Tell me if you got the belt.
告诉我你是否拿到了腰带。
Oh yeah, people say that all the time.
哦，是的，人们总是这么说。
Now, I watched this episode and to me, it's a hundred percent clear he got the belt.
现在，我看了这一集，对我来说，百分百确定他获得了腰带。
Not just because he walks in the room, you know, and it's actually like this, you know, the giggling and it's like, it's actually a beautiful kind of, a booger, it's like lit, it was like the briefcase in Pulp Fiction.
不仅仅是因为他走进房间，你知道，实际上就像这样，你知道，咯咯地笑，就像，它实际上是一种美丽的鼻屎，它就像点燃的，就像低俗小说中的公文包。
Yes, exactly, it's the briefcase of Pulp Fiction, that's exactly right, they're kind of fairytale below.
是的，没错，就是《低俗小说》里的公文包，没错，下面就是童话故事。
You have this luminous look on your face, but I also feel like this is like when they asked David Chase about what happens when the Sopranos smashes the black, this is on parallel.
你脸上有这种发光的表情，但我也觉得这就像当他们问大卫·蔡斯《黑道家族》粉碎黑色时会发生什么，这是平行的。
And like Chase finally admitted that Tony got capped, I always thought that Ted got laid.
就像蔡斯最终承认托尼被限制一样，我一直认为特德被上床了。
Well, I'll tell you this, it's not just walking into the Pulp Fiction.
好吧，我告诉你，这不仅仅是走进低俗小说。
It's the next day to it, it's the next morning.
这是第二天，这是第二天早上。
It's the way he is with Barney in the booth.
这就是他和巴尼在展位上的相处方式。
And I would say that Ted has never been more confident than that moment in the booth.
我想说，特德从未像在展位上的那一刻那样自信。
And is driving Barney out of his mind and I don't think Ted could fake that energy.
正在让巴尼失去理智，我认为特德无法伪造这种能量。
Ted is living with that energy.
泰德就生活在这种能量之中。
I think he definitely did it.
我想他肯定做到了。
I think he did it.
我认为他做到了。
We're answering it now, folks.
伙计们，我们现在正在回答这个问题。
He definitely did it.
他绝对做到了。
Wilco is playing.
威尔科正在演奏。
That's the song that plays you out.
这就是让你兴奋的歌曲。
It's Wilco's, the Silico song passenger side.
这是 Wilco 的，Silico 歌曲乘客侧。
If it's Wilco, it's a three-way, you know the way I was always confused when people would ask me I would be like, I think it's pretty clear.
如果是威尔科，那就是三路，你知道当人们问我时我总是感到困惑，我会说，我认为这是很清楚的。
Yeah, but I love the fact here, but also goes to the wholesome, this thing.
是的，但我喜欢这里的事实，但也注重健康，这件事。
Like, I don't know if I don't think it was a standards note.
就像，我不知道我是否认为这不是标准说明。
I don't think it was a standards note.
我不认为这是标准说明。
I think it was a choice that you wanted to keep it.
我认为这是你想要保留的选择。
We want to keep it vague and I like that people come and ask.
我们希望保持模糊，我喜欢人们过来询问。
I think it's cool.
我认为这很酷。
Cause I think it's like it is, we're talking about the public fiction briefcase still right now, 30 years later.
因为我认为事情就是这样，30 年后的今天，我们仍在谈论公共小说公文包。
What was in that fucking briefcase?
那个该死的公文包里装的是什么？
It's just great not to quite now.
现在还没有这样就太好了。
I almost want to leave it open.
我几乎想把它打开。
But if I'm honest, I would say, I, I think he, I think Ted, I think Ted had a good night.
但如果我说实话，我会说，我，我认为他，我认为特德，我认为特德度过了一个美好的夜晚。
I would give yes, yes, but I would say that, you know, when the quantum reality, who knows?
我会说是的，是的，但我会说，你知道，当量子现实出现时，谁知道呢？
Who knows?
谁知道？
Everything's happening all at once anyway.
无论如何，一切都同时发生。
I will say in the grand scheme of things, slightly odd story to tell your children.
我会说，在宏伟的计划中，给你的孩子们讲一个稍微奇怪的故事。
Well, it's presented, it's presented in the narration.
嗯，它呈现了，它在旁白中呈现了。
I think we could have done a little more with this, but it is presented as if it's kind of like framed as kids, there's some stories you tell and some stories you don't tell.
我认为我们可以在这方面做得更多一点，但它的呈现方式就像是像孩子一样，有一些你讲的故事，也有一些你不讲的故事。
And the narrator kind of never comes back around and lands the plane really.
叙述者再也没有回来并真正让飞机着陆。
So it's, I think it's sort of like, the implication is we're maybe seeing one that is just in Ted's memory, or Ted's telling us some tiny part of the story.
所以，我认为这有点像，这意味着我们可能看到的是特德记忆中的一个，或者特德告诉我们故事的一小部分。
So I think we tried to speak with that in the opening edition.
所以我认为我们试图在开幕版中讨论这一点。
I think we should have somehow tapped it again.
我认为我们应该以某种方式再次利用它。
It's true.
这是真的。
It's so hard.
太难了。
You have 21 minutes, Dave, right?
戴夫，你有 21 分钟，对吗？
And these stories, it's like, think about how much happens emotionally in the story.
这些故事，就像，想想故事中发生了多少情感上的事情。
It's 21 minutes.
已经21分钟了。
It's just crazy.
这太疯狂了。
I know, that's what I think, I think the half hour sitcom format is such a brilliant training ground for everything else.
我知道，这就是我的想法，我认为半小时的情景喜剧格式是其他一切的绝佳训练场。
I mean, because you're obliged to compress and condense and like bullion cube.
我的意思是，因为你必须压缩和凝结，就像金块一样。
Like every moment is like super concentrated bullion cube of emotion and comedy, you know?
就像每个时刻都像超级浓缩的情感和喜剧的金块，你知道吗？
Yes.
是的。
Well, you left himium and spread your tramp stamp butterfly wings to go become an Oscar nominee for a phenomenal movie called The Holdovers.
好吧，你离开了氦气，展开了你的流浪者邮票蝴蝶翅膀，去成为一部名为《保留》的非凡电影的奥斯卡提名者。
If anybody listening has not seen that, just run to that.
如果听的人没有看到这一点，就跑到那儿去。
And it is a Christmas canon classic.
这是圣诞节的经典之作。
To me, that's in the canon of great Christmas films now too.
对我来说，这也是现在伟大的圣诞电影的经典。
In addition, in other ways, it's a great movie.
此外，从其他方面来说，这也是一部很棒的电影。
So congrats on that, buddy.
所以恭喜你，伙计。
Dave, this is a pleasure, my friend.
戴夫，我很高兴，我的朋友。
We got you for one beautiful season of the show, and it was a gift.
我们为您带来了一个美好的演出季，这是一份礼物。
I'm sorry, we haven't seen more of each other over the years.
抱歉，这些年我们没有再见面了。
I always loved our on-set chats, and maybe when we find each other in the same town, let's grab a meal.
我一直很喜欢我们在片场聊天，也许当我们在同一个城镇找到彼此时，我们就去吃顿饭吧。
Oh my God, I always want to highlight some of my life.
天哪，我总是想强调我生活中的一些事情。
Likewise, buddy.
同样，哥们。
I remember when I told you that having Michael Gross be my dad, who was the dad on Family Ties, was like one of those vertigo-inducing moments like this guy from Ohio.
我记得当我告诉你让迈克尔·格罗斯成为我的父亲时，他是《家庭关系》中的父亲，就像这个来自俄亥俄州的家伙那样令人眩晕的时刻之一。
You know, having a threesome with Winnie Cooper was very strange.
你知道，和温妮·库珀三人行是很奇怪的。
And like unbelievable, like to a kid who grew up under yours.
难以置信，就像在你的手下长大的孩子一样。
That's a weird thing to be able to say.
能说出这样的话真是奇怪。
It is.
这是。
Yeah, you kind of...
是的，你有点...
That's a Winnie Cooper, man.
那是温妮·库珀，伙计。
Well, Winnie is his character on Kelly, I think, on the freaking gigs.
嗯，我想，温妮是他在《凯利》中扮演的角色，在那些疯狂的演出中。
I mean, from someone who doesn't like to be referred to as this character's name, And I'm like, I don't know when he took that.
我的意思是，来自一个不喜欢被称为这个角色的名字的人，我想，我不知道他什么时候取的这个名字。
But it was, they were so funny.
但事实就是如此，他们太有趣了。
And it was, you needed actors who, like all three of us needed to sell this thing.
是的，你需要演员，就像我们三个人一样，需要推销这个东西。
Yeah.
是的。
Like you said, in the wrong hands or with the wrong tone, like it was a thin balance meme we were walking on in any misstep we could have fallen in many, in a ditch in any direction, right?
就像你说的，在错误的人手中或以错误的语气，就像我们走在一个薄弱的平衡模因上，任何失误我们都可能跌倒在许多地方，在任何方向的沟渠中，对吧？
Yeah, yeah, totally.
是的，是的，完全如此。
They were great.
他们很棒。
Thank you, busy.
谢谢你，忙着。
Thank you, Danica.
谢谢你，丹妮卡。
You guys were great.
你们太棒了。
is our third Freaks and Geeks alum that we had on the show.
是我们节目中第三位《怪胎与极客》的演员。
We had Martin Starr and Sam Levine and now Busy Phillips.
我们有马丁·斯塔尔和萨姆·莱文，现在还有忙碌的菲利普斯。
Of course, Jason Siegel makes it four.
当然，贾森·西格尔（Jason Siegel）获得了第四名。
I forgot one, Jason.
我忘了一个，杰森。
So we're huge fans of Freaks and Geeks as is obvious with the casting.
所以我们是《怪胎与极客》的忠实粉丝，这一点从演员阵容中就可以明显看出。
Yeah, I just wanted to highlight a couple of things that really amused me.
是的，我只是想强调一些真正让我感到有趣的事情。
The episode starts again with a mystery, the belt.
这一集再次从一个神秘的腰带开始。
Like what's the belt, right?
比如腰带是什么，对吧？
Is the belt?
是腰带吗？
Like stay tuned, right?
喜欢继续关注，对吧？
We have to figure out what the belt is.
我们必须弄清楚腰带是什么。
And then there, of course, there's an actual belt.
当然，还有一条真正的腰带。
So is it all three?
那么这三个都是吗？
Is it Robin, Lily and Marshall?
是罗宾、莉莉和马歇尔吗？
Or is it just Barney, Lily and Marshall?
或者只是巴尼、莉莉和马歇尔？
Or is it just Barney and Marshall who gave a Rob Greenberg?
或者只是巴尼和马歇尔给出了罗布·格林伯格？
Yes.
是的。
Yes, and I was watching with Rebecca and she was like, that's a Greenberg, yes.
是的，我和丽贝卡一起看，她说，那是格林伯格，是的。
That's one of our writers, Rob Greenberg, when I was like, yes, like we've done a lot of good idea.
这是我们的作家之一，罗布·格林伯格，当时我想，是的，就像我们做了很多好主意一样。
Like, we always look at the obvious answer.
就像，我们总是看显而易见的答案。
Opportunities on the show to give a Greenbergy and yes.
在节目中给予格林伯格的机会是的。
It was definitely Barney and Marshall did Lilly, oh wow, she also in that doing that, yes, she might have been.
这绝对是巴尼和马歇尔干的，莉莉，哦哇，她也在这么做，是的，她可能是这样。
But that was, we, I remember writing it in the description, having some writing in the description, parenthetical Greenberg.
但那是，我们，我记得在描述中写了它，在描述中写了一些内容，附加了格林伯格。
Greenberg.
格林伯格。
And everyone knew, everyone knew it's over.
每个人都知道，每个人都知道一切都结束了。
Everyone knew, everyone knew, yeah, they knew what the read should be, if it said parenthetical Greenberg.
每个人都知道，每个人都知道，是的，他们知道读到的内容应该是什么，如果它说的是括号里的格林伯格。
I was really struck just how, it's almost like without Barney, like the way that Ted talks to Trudy, it's like he's got moves, like he's very charming.
我真的很震惊，就像没有巴尼一样，就像泰德和特鲁迪说话的方式一样，就像他有动作一样，就像他非常迷人一样。
and you can understand why, but I think there's something about Barney because Barney is so, he gamifies the whole thing.
你可以理解为什么，但我认为巴尼有一些东西，因为巴尼就是这样，他把整个事情游戏化了。
I think it makes Ted self-conscious.
我认为这让特德感到不自在。
Yes, Ted seems very uninhibited.
是的，特德看起来很不羁。
He's very well.
他很好。
They're fucking with us.
他们在玩弄我们。
It's easier, I think, to talk to women, you have some history with than it is, not necessarily, but I always found talking to a stranger to be very difficult, just approaching someone at a bar.
我认为，与女性交谈更容易，你有一定的历史，但不一定，但我总是发现与陌生人交谈非常困难，就像在酒吧接近某人一样。
And they had some history, and she approached him.
他们有一些历史，她接近了他。
was a genius choice in the story that it was someone that he knew.
在故事中，他选择了一个他认识的人，这是一个天才的选择。
Someone he had, there was some kind of momentum and chemistry.
他有一个人，有某种动力和化学反应。
Like that was great.
那样就太好了。
I don't know if that was Dave's pitch to you, but it being a Trudy was such a good, it just, you need it to be that.
我不知道这是否是戴夫向你推销的，但成为特鲁迪真是太好了，只是，你需要这样。
If Rachel would say, oh, what was he like as a lover and she'd be like, I don't remember we were blackout.
如果雷切尔说，哦，他作为情人是什么样的，而她会说，我不记得我们停电了。
There's something with a pineapple.
有一种东西跟菠萝有关。
I'm not sure what it would have happened.
我不确定会发生什么。
Yeah.
是的。
I love, there's a little moment.
我爱，有一个小时刻。
I noticed these, some of these things that all All the characters do, but I was doing something that really made me laugh when they were doing their sorority chant.
我注意到所有角色都会做的一些事情，但当他们唱联谊会口号时，我正在做一些真正让我发笑的事情。
Did you notice I was like dancing a little bit with it?
你注意到我想和它一起跳舞吗？
Yes, you're very loose in a very loose episode.
是的，你在一个非常松散的情节中非常松散。
It's a very physical performance.
这是一个非常需要体力的表演。
I like when he tells the beers, be cool.
我喜欢他告诉啤酒要冷静。
Be cool.
冷静点。
Yeah.
是的。
Talk to the beers a lot.
经常与啤酒交谈。
That was very funny.
那很有趣。
Yeah.
是的。
I like Barney's line given the choice always party with Dr. Strange Love.
我喜欢巴尼的台词，因为我总是选择与奇爱博士一起聚会。
Strange.
奇怪的。
Dr. Strange Love.
奇爱博士。
Genius.
天才。
That feels like it's straight out of Hemington's brain.
这感觉就像直接出自海明顿的大脑。
Doesn't it?
不是吗？
direct You know there was something I try to do this thing in my screenplay is that my my producer and dear friend Jesse Hera loves Where I try to avoid proper nouns, but if they are proper nouns, they have to almost be iconic Like it has to be like Beethoven it can't be Like Justin Bieber or something like I want and I mean Justin Bieber's kind of iconic at this point I mean, he is, but I want, I feel like sometimes when you're in the land of proper nouns, they should have some real history to them, like some real weight to them.
直接 你知道我在剧本中尝试做的事情是我的制作人和亲爱的朋友杰西·赫拉喜欢的地方我试图避免专有名词，但如果它们是专有名词，它们必须几乎是标志性的就像它必须像贝多芬一样它不能像贾斯汀·比伯或类似我想要的东西我的意思是贾斯汀·比伯在这一点上具有标志性我的意思是，他是，但我想要，有时当你在这片土地上时我感觉对于专有名词来说，它们应该有一些真实的历史，就像它们有一些真实的分量一样。
And like Dr. Strange love.
和奇异博士的爱情一样。
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
It has historical import.
它具有历史意义。
It's like everything has to feel important in this story because the story is about something very important.
就好像这个故事中的一切都必须感觉很重要，因为这个故事是关于一些非常重要的事情。
And I love another Hemington straight out of his brain is that thing.
我爱另一个海明顿，就是因为他的大脑。
Don't postpone joy, because I think that's something he really will say sometimes.
不要推迟快乐，因为我认为有时他确实会这么说。
Yeah.
是的。
He's just such an intense guy Dave so intense.
他是一个非常热情的人，戴夫非常热情。
He's so great.
他太棒了。
He's like he he's very philosophical and deep, too Like you Dave saying don't postpone joy like he means that shit.
他就像他一样，他非常有哲理，也很深刻，就像你戴夫说的那样，不要推迟快乐，就像他的意思那样。
He's like let's live like let's carpet the DM here Like he's very good.
他就像让我们一起生活吧，就像让我们在这里铺上地毯一样，就像他非常好一样。
He is that guy.
他就是那个人。
I like when Ted says I'm never not wearing a suit again Yeah, how's dad's colon let's look like why did I just why did they just say that.
我喜欢特德说我再也不会不穿西装了是啊，爸爸的结肠怎么样，让我们​​看看为什么我只是为什么他们这么说。
I like to Barney's bylaws for the belt.
我喜欢巴尼的腰带章程。
That was really funny.
那真的很有趣。
Yeah, really funny.
是的，真的很有趣。
Again, lawyer speak.
再次，律师发言。
It's like written like a lawyerly contract.
就像律师合同一样写的。
That was probably very Hemington too.
这可能也是非常海明顿的。
Yeah.
是的。
I think if I was going to update this episode, I would probably ding Turkish lesbians.
我想如果我要更新这一集，我可能会喜欢土耳其女同性恋。
Yeah, that jumped out of me as a little clunky and maybe unpleasant, like maybe not super thoughtful when it says to me.
是的，这让我觉得有点笨拙，也许不愉快，就像它对我说的那样，可能不是很周到。
I love the text that Ted clearly sent in a panic too fast.
我喜欢特德显然在恐慌中太快地发送的短信。
He says, we're combing up SARS, and Marshall's like, what does that mean?
他说，我们正在梳理SARS，马歇尔之类的，这是什么意思？
It's a terrifying, it's a SARS joke.
这是一个可怕的事情，这是一个非典笑话。
SARS, it's a SARS, yeah, he's afraid of SARS.
非典，非典，是的，他害怕非典。
One thing that Jason did, this is a very seagullian thing when he said the pigeon been crapped on the fire escape and it, and he just does that.
杰森做了一件事，这是一件非常海鸥的事情，当他说鸽子被拉在防火梯上时，他就这么做了。
Yeah, that was a really funny, weird timing, funny, weird, like, no one else would do that but Jason.
是的，那真是一个有趣、奇怪的时机，有趣、奇怪，就像，除了杰森，没有人会这么做。
Yes, but he would say, I don't know it's weird.
是的，但他会说，我不知道这很奇怪。
That's the only way I can think of to do it.
这是我能想到的唯一方法。
That's his whenever you ask him about that, he goes, to me, it's not weird.
每当你问他这个问题时，他都会说，对我来说，这并不奇怪。
That's the only way to do it.
这是唯一的方法。
It's how I hear it in my head.
这就是我在脑海中听到的。
He's not trying to do it.
他并不想这么做。
That's, that's the key to his genius.
这就是他天才的关键。
Yeah.
是的。
It's head fussing with his hair is really funny.
它的头在头发上乱动，真的很有趣。
Coming back like three times, just go.
回来三回了，就走吧。
great energy.
巨大的能量。
The Greek chorus of those guys, his mission control team, it's just very good energy.
这些人的希腊合唱团，他的任务控制团队，都是非常好的能量。
And when Barney decides to really help him, it's great.
当巴尼决定真正帮助他时，那就太好了。
And all the fantasy sequence, that was great.
所有的幻想序列都很棒。
This sweating and the image of the belt in the head, that was all like, you can't do that, that's not a live audience show.
这种出汗和头上带子的形象，就像，你不能这样做，那不是现场观众表演。
That's where the hybrid comes in.
这就是混合动力的用武之地。
I also thought, this was a really funny thought.
我还想，这是一个非常有趣的想法。
He gives them a massage, right?
他给他们按摩，对吗？
And I was like, He learned from Gaille.
我当时想，他是向盖尔学习的。
He learned from Gaille how to massage a woman.
他从盖尔那里学会了如何给女人按摩。
Right.
正确的。
That did just happen.
那确实发生了。
That did just cross his path as a thing.
那件事确实横亘在他的道路上。
You're right.
你说得对。
See, you learned something from everyone in your life.
看，你从生活中的每个人身上都学到了一些东西。
Even that's right.
即使这样也是对的。
That's right.
这是正确的。
Never wish anyone away who crosses your path.
永远不要希望任何走过你道路的人离开。
They all are teachers on the way.
他们都是路上的老师。
So I'm going to read a letter that I actually, this was someone reached out via Instagram and they didn't write this for public consumption so I'm not gonna say who it was from but it was it really I sent it to Craig and Alec and it really moved us so I just wanted to this was a response to actually no let me let me say this it was a response to something I posted about the episode with Jessica how we met a listener the the woman who lost her husband who wrote about feeling differently about how I met your mother and the wake of this grief.
所以我要读一封信，实际上，这是有人通过 Instagram 联系的，他们写的这封信不是为了公众消费，所以我不会说这封信是谁写的，但它确实是我寄给克雷格和亚历克的，这真的让我们感动，所以我只是想这是对我发布的关于杰西卡的那一集的回应，我们如何遇见一位听众，失去丈夫的女人写了关于我如何遇见你的母亲和你的母亲的不同感受。从这种悲伤中醒来。
And we did a whole episode about her, which is one of the ones, I would say we're most proud of this episode, one of the ones.
我们制作了一整集关于她的节目，这是其中之一，我想说我们对这一集感到最自豪，这是其中之一。
Yeah, that was a beautiful episode, thanks to her.
是的，这是一个美丽的插曲，谢谢她。
Yeah, so I let people know in a video that I was just urging people to check this one out because it was really wonderful.
是的，所以我在视频中让人们知道我只是敦促人们看看这个，因为它真的很棒。
And I said, let me know how I met your mother has changed for you over the years.
我说，让我知道我是如何认识你母亲的，这些年来你的母亲发生了变化。
That was my prompt.
这就是我的提示。
So this is what this person wrote me.
这就是这个人写给我的。
I just saw the last thing you posted and I wanted to let you know how important the show was for me, too.
我刚刚看到你发布的最后一条内容，我想让你知道这个节目对我来说也有多重要。
I was a teenager when I started watching Himyam and life was a little bit tough back then.
当我开始看 Himyam 的时候，我还是个十几岁的孩子，那时的生活有点艰难。
I was in high school and I was being bullied.
我当时正在上高中，我被欺负了。
Every day was like a nightmare for me.
每一天对我来说都像一场噩梦。
There was a point where I actually wanted to die.
有一段时间我真的想死。
But I remember how my safe moment was when I got home from high school and I turned the TV on and watched him.
但我记得当我从高中回到家时，我打开电视看着他，那是多么安全的时刻。
That was one of the things that kept me going, and also one of the things that made me who I am today.
这是让我继续前进的因素之一，也是造就今天的我的因素之一。
Yesterday, I started watching him again with my boyfriend, and I realized that I know the show basically line by line sometimes.
昨天，我和男朋友又开始看他，我意识到有时我基本上是逐句了解这个节目的。
It will always be my comfort show, and it will always save me.
这将永远是我的安慰秀，它永远会拯救我。
So thank you for the part that you took there.
谢谢你在那里的参与。
You were my favorite character back then.
那时你是我最喜欢的角色。
I always dreamed about meeting my own Ted Mosby.
我一直梦想着见到我自己的泰德·莫斯比。
Wow.
哇。
That's amazing.
太棒了。
The idea that the show was the safety place is so lovely.
这个节目是安全场所的想法真是太可爱了。
Thanks for letting me know that.
谢谢你让我知道这一点。
If any listeners want to send us a letter, written or drop us a voice note that we sometimes play at the beginning of the show, we like to read letters in the C-block.
如果任何听众想给我们写一封信，或者给我们留言（我们有时会在节目开始时播放），我们喜欢在 C 区朗读信件。
Go to how we made your mother.com, HWMYM.
看看我们如何创建您的 mother.com，HWMYM。
Go to contact and follow the directions.
前往联系方式并按照说明进行操作。
It's pretty easy.
这很容易。
We've gotten thousands of responses and people reaching out, and it's really one of our favorite things about doing this, to just hear about this thing we created and how it's continued to affect people.
我们收到了成千上万的回复和人们的伸出援手，这确实是我们最喜欢做的事情之一，就是听到我们创造的这个东西以及它如何继续影响人们。
So thank you for that, and for all of the letters and notes we get.
因此，感谢您，以及我们收到的所有信件和便条。
And we, we'll see you next time.
而我们，我们下次再见。
This was really fun.
这真的很有趣。
We want to thank Dave Hemmison for joining us.
我们要感谢戴夫·赫米森加入我们。
Thanks.
谢谢。
And thanks for watching and listening along, and we'll see you next time when we do episode four of season three.
感谢您的观看和聆听，我们下次第三季第四集时再见。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
All sins are forgiven.
所有的罪孽都被宽恕了。
In New York City."
在纽约市。”
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并执行制作。
And it's presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
它由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 提供和分发。
The show is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey, and the show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev.
该节目还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作人，由我亚历克·列夫制作和编辑。
Our co-producer is Doug Matica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, a point of blue studios, and our Gen Z Masters, our digital content producer Emily Blumberg, and associate producer, Catherine Grove.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Alex Reeves（blue studio 的一名成员），我们的 Gen Z Masters、我们的数字内容制作人 Emily Blumberg 以及副制作人 Catherine Grove。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help to spread the word.
它确实有助于传播信息。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Sam Theobold and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢 Sam Theobold 和 Elliot Connors。
Go to HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's muse letters on Substack, and check out his music and everything else at Joshradner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的缪斯信件，并在 Joshradner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, that's not how it happened, wherever books are sold, and read his other published writing at CraigThomasWriter.com.
订购克雷格·托马斯的处女作，无论在哪里出售书籍，事情都不是这样发生的，并在 CraigThomasWriter.com 上阅读他出版的其他作品。
And you could subscribe to my own dead father's society on Substack.
你可以在 Substack 上订阅我已故父亲的社团。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise funds for congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这展示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the make a difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“有所作为”选项卡。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
Real question, it just hit me, am I in love with you or just New York City?
真正的问题，我突然想到，我爱的是你还是只爱纽约市？